theories in his book and to explain his
ideas on the implication of japanese
lobbying on american national
sovereignty
pat cho author of the book agents of
influence how japan's lobbyists in the
united states manipulate america's
political and economic system
what do you think of the japanese
i think they're very productive people i
think
they have enormous organizational skills
i think they build first-rate
products and i think they have the
capacity to come and understand our
political system
and be able when necessary
to work their will to their own economic
advantage here have you spent much time
in japan yes i am
in fact one of the things that i did in
the process of doing this book
was go and study the japanese political
system talked with
many members of the diet in the
government
talked to the private secretaries in the
japanese system the people who raise and
dispense the monies what i wanted to do
was to try to understand the japanese
mindset on politics there to just see
how it works what i found was very
interesting
that in japan there are really three
power centers there are the bureaucrats
who are very confident and very good
they represent the very best out of
their education system
you have the politicians and then you
have the business interest
the business interests attempt to
influence the bureaucrats who play a
much more important role in japan than
civil servants do here in this country
but they are able to influence the diet
or the their parliamentary body through
money and
quite literally the money that is
expended is enormous
far beyond anything that we know in this
country in the last election cycle in
japan
in the year leading up to it
over four billion dollars was raised for
political purposes uh to put into
perspective that was five times the
amount that was spent in 1988 on all of
our political races uh presidential
house and senate so when the japanese
come to the united states they just see
political expenditures and lobbying is
just another business expenditure and
equally important they see the levels
required to buy influence here very
cheap in comparison to what they're used
to in their own home market
do they have any
public requirements i mean public
accountability for the four billion
dollars that they raise for politics
over there they in the home office will
report part of that money
what we will see is somewhere in the
neighborhood
of about two billion dollars of that is
reported
another two billion dollars according to
knowledgeable insiders is unreported
money in the process of doing this book
i
talked to the private secretary
of a former prime minister uh former
prime minister tanaka who was really the
the person behind the scene in japanese
politics for almost 20 years and he
talked about going out and raising money
in cash
and then coming back and taking that
cash and literally a satchel where he
would have as much as a million and a
half dollars in japanese currency at a
time and passing it out
to
the supporters
of mr tanaka something else that's very
different in the japanese political
system than here
is
each member of the japanese diet
is given enough money to hire
two or three staff people each member
will need a minimum of 16 to 18 staff
people
the money to pay
for those additional staff people must
be raised from the special interest
groups themselves and so in a very real
sense the
special interest groups the business
agricultural other interests finance the
staffing of the individual
diet members in addition to financing
the political cost it would be as though
special interest in this country paid
for the congressional staff
in your book there is a picture here of
former president jimmy carter who is the
gentleman he's running with there ryochi
sasakawa who
is a man that formed one
of the more radical fascist parties in
japan
in the 1930s
he was a man that
agitated for
nationalist policies agitated for war
was
had his own
private fifteen thousand
person army black shirted army benito
mussolini
was
one of his idols
he went and spent time in italy with
benito mussolini was a member of the
government during the war was imprisoned
after the war
by the occupation authorities as a class
a war criminal
he controls
a major part of the legal gambling
industry in japan today
his gambling interests
produce
hundreds of billions of dollars he has
given away
estimates of up to 400 million dollars
over the past couple of decades
he has invested
over 20 million dollars
in the activities the library of former
president jimmy carter
and what is not in that book but what i
discovered after
the book was completed
earlier this year he gave
one million dollars
to help finance the nixon library
another picture of him who's he here
with benito mussolini
who uh he says in his writings was
one of his political heroes pretty tough
on jimmy carter in your book
yes i'm fairly tough uh the point that i
make is that
we have a
a new
post-presidential standard and that
standard
is that they can accept money from a
variety of sources in fairness to jimmy
carter uh his activities are charitable
and and
otherwise uh president reagan
took
some money personally for his speaking
tour two million dollars but he also
solicited money from japanese
corporations sony among others
to help him build and equip his
presidential library one of the points
that i'm making here
is that we have a flaw in our laws
that in effect say
that a president
must raise private monies to build these
presidential libraries which are in a
sense a memorial to the president
they are
their own pyramids in effect
and yet the federal government will only
take over the
operating expenses after the facility
has been built i think what we really
need to do
is have the federal government
pay for these libraries because it gives
too many opportunities
for
rich people here and abroad
to curry influence with the president
while they're still in office as the
presidents seek this money to build the
libraries
as you know
you've lived how long you live around
washington oh 15 years
where's home by the way originally
originally it was a little town
called red oak which is
by walks of hatchets between waco and
dallas
my parents were cotton farmers in texas
in texas okay but as i was saying as you
know
there are a lot of people in this town
that really don't like you
well they don't like me now and
you know a lot of it's just word of
mouth and you hear people around town
talking about why do you think they
don't like you
i think
the
dislike comes
in some element because many people are
lobbyists
they've been through the revolving door
they're making a great deal of money i'm
raising the question that what they do
and what they have done
may not be in the national interest and
i'm certainly saying that it does not
uh elevate
the concept of
public service in this country to have
this revolving door so i don't think
that they like that criticism none of us
like
other people i think are criticizing me
because they think
that in raising these issues that i'm
arguing specific positions on trade or
upon foreign investment or on economics
i'm not
what i'm in effect arguing
is that our political system has some
flaws both how we raise money how we
recruit people for the top jobs and what
we permit when they leave office
so i i think it's natural since i'm
raising criticisms that
people would respond to negative work
are you feeling the heat
well i've
certainly
don't like
being criticized but on the other hand i
think the issue is sufficiently
important that it merits uh raising and
i'm certainly not hesitant obviously
about raising it
let me read
the toughest criticism i could find in
print okay michael kinsley yes trb
new republic
uh choate is a classic washington type a
variation on the lobbyist and super
lawyer he excoriates the policy hustler
well it's a i think that's a silly uh
comment
uh i've written a book describing how
politics operates
i'm saying that there are flaws that we
should not permit the revolving door we
should not permit foreign corporations
to operate within our society i'm
raising a legitimate political criticism
i'm putting in a book i'm standing forth
to stand behind the book and take the
criticism
i don't think that's hustling
he makes his living marketing ideas his
income depends on keeping those ideas
simple extreme and appealing until
recently he was vice president for
policy analysis at trw corporation nice
work if you can get it
do you think the idea of wanting to
close the revolving door is extreme or
is the idea of wanting
to close all of the exemptions in the
lobbying
acts that would require all who lobby
to register so you could have sunshine
so you could know
who is speaking for whom extreme
is it extreme to say that we do not wish
foreign money within our politics those
are the three central recommendations of
this book i think that he really went
overboard on that criticism what do you
have any idea why michael kinsley was so
critical of you no i really don't
no i do not know him i've not met him
but i think that that
piece
was filled
with many personal and ad hominem
attacks
that in truth
skirt away from the main issue and the
main issue is is that we have a
political system today
in which money plays far too important a
role and we have a political system
today where too many people in effect
use their public office as a means
eventually for personal gain and in the
process i think we discourage many
competent and dedicated uh
people from coming into government
okay there's some more and i want to ask
you because everybody talks about this
behind the scenes as you sure know just
lately children trw parted ways
apparently over agents of influence cho
isn't talking for the record this was
written some time ago are you talking
for the record today did you part over
this book uh yes i did part over this
book and
michael kinsley is very wrong in his
statement
later on in that piece he
talks about a martyr with a golden
parachute i have no golden parachute
from trw i have no consulting
arrangement with tr
no
i had no severance arrangement
with trw had he checked with me
he could have confirmed that very easily
how long did you work for trw ten years
why did they fire you over this book
the difficulty over this book is
the japanese government and the japanese
are
very
insensitive
to any criticism
and what would have happened
is
trw would have suffered
on their sales
in japan uh because it would have been
uh construed that this book uh
represented the corporate view it it did
not you know quite diff quite honestly
the japanese have some difficulty
understanding that in america
books are written by authors and they
represent individual views they find it
very difficult
to understand how someone in an
organization
might have a view that is different
than the organization or that it may or
may not represent the views
of the organization itself
there's a saying in japan
which is that the nail that stands out
must be driven down and what i document
in the book
is how time after time critics of japan
will suddenly find themselves under
enormous pressure or there will be
attempts to discredit them
jim fallows for example
was discredited jim fallows is one of
america's most distinguished journalist
i think his reporting is fair and
accurate right for the atlantic rights
for the uh atlantic uh monthly
uh
carol von warfran who is a very
knowledgeable and distinguished dutch
journalist found himself in a
circumstance when he wrote a book that
described how
the politics in japan works in which the
japanese ambassador in the netherlands
where his headquarters of his newspaper
was located went to his publisher and
said this book will cause great
difficulty in dutch japanese
relationships
carol von wolfran has been subject to
intense
personal attack
that has nothing to do with his work
clyde prestowitz did
a very good book that describes the
inside of american trade negotiating
relationships with the japanese and he
has been
very falsely labeled as a racist
as a japan basher as anti-japan
it's a standard technique it's a
standard
ad hominem approach
where when criticism arises
the
japanese and many of the people who are
paid to represent them
will attempt to discredit the critic
so that they do not
so the the public discussion focuses on
that person rather than on the substance
of the debate that is the purpose of ad
hominem attacks let me then go to
continue on the uh on the attack side of
it there sure some other articles that
have been written
people say
well pat choke criticizes but really in
effect all he's doing is making lots of
money off this book and the japanese
have bought the rights to this book for
300 000
well it means i'll get my expense money
back at least that it costs me to do the
investigation i'm at least pleased for
that
is uh
is that one of the is that the reason
you wrote the book to make the money oh
absolutely not i mean i've written
uh
three other books that uh where i've
lost money on every book
as an author when you write a book you
just must assume to be realistic that
you're not going to make any money on
the book i wrote this book because i
think this is a very important issue
i think that one of our basic problems
of governance today is the systemic
identifiable public corruption
that exists
legal but nonetheless corrupt
and that that corruption
is in effect perverting our ability as a
nation to honestly talk about our future
and to honestly deal with many of our
problems the problem that i describe
here is the same problem
in washington that permitted the hud
scandal where a series of insiders were
able to get preferential treatment and
misuse roughly two billion dollars worth
of money where uh savings and loan
people were able to get members of
congress and the administration to look
the other way while they plundered
the snl snl industry
and now
since influence is for sale here foreign
governments and foreign corporations are
coming here attempting to buy decisions
in such a way so that through political
means they can gain an economic
advantage and the important thing
that i show in this book is that while
japan is the example i use because they
have the largest most sophisticated and
the most effective
political effort
in the appendix to the book i identify
200 former officials during the 1980s
that were
held the highest most sensitive
positions but then
subsequently registered with the justice
department as foreign agents and went to
work to represent foreign governments
and foreign corporations in washington
is two-thirds
of the clients
that are listed there
are clients other than japan or japanese
countries uh companies the point being
is the rest of the world knows
that you can buy influence so easily in
this town and so they're coming here and
buying it
we're showing the audience a little bit
it's hard to read this but what we do
what we did do in order to be able to
discuss this we've taken some of these
names and the dollar amount in the
countries that they represent and put
them on graphics
we're going to go to that right now and
show you the first one you can look over
there on the screen um
richard allen was the national security
advisor in the reagan administration
early years explain what
what that's telling us there
uh what it says is that
he represented
an organization from south korea that
helped organize the olympics that had
some political involvement perhaps back
with the federal government and he was
paid 972 000 during the decade of the
80s or some period of the 80s for that
representation
the 1.58 million dollars was paid to him
by the uh by a taiwanese
governmental group let's look at the
next one
christine bliss assistant attorney
general assistant general counsel the
u.s trade representative
the law firm of mud rose in new york
what that says is that mudrose the law
firm
was paid 11 million dollars and that
christine bliss was one of what turned
out to be several people who were paid
to assist the toshiba corporation in a
variety of activities including
defeating the congressional efforts to
impose sanctions on toshiba in 1987 and
1988
when toshiba
sold
technology to the soviet union that
permitted them to manufacture propeller
blades where their submarines
could go undetected by the u.s navy next
name robert cassidy general counsel
again the united states trade
representative which is here in
washington
uh wilmer cutler pickering law firm in
washington lufthansa
airlines of west germany 7 million seven
hundred thousand dollars that reflects
again that uh uh his firm
uh was paid uh that amount of money
other people from that firm were also
uh in vo involved including lloyd cutler
who was been general counsel to jimmy
carter do you know who robert cassidy is
do you remember what administration he
served in he served in the um i believe
he was
briefly in the carter administration
next
john culver former united states senator
the law firm of aaron fox toyota motor
company 1.1 million and also another
firm in japan for 941 thousand you know
what we find is
what was interesting to me in doing this
research
is
my publisher would give me roughly 50
pages to do this appendix and in essence
what i'm doing there is just going to
the public records where
people have signed that they are the
representative and they present
the documentation of how much money that
they've been paid
and reporting uh what is on the public
record now it took some difficulty
to track and put this down but what
really there were two things well there
were really three things
that struck me in in doing this
one of those things
is i could just as easily could have
done a hundred pages as i did 50 pages
and the second thing that struck me
in doing this
was that the vast majority of the people
unlike the people that
are shown in this graphics
are people uh that essentially are
unknown even by and large into the
washington community let me just tell
you a second because we've got stewart
eisenstadt's name on the screen i want
to show the audience that this amount of
pages in your book right here was
devoted to this chart showing all of the
money that has been made by insiders in
washington and then law firms the people
who used to serve here
that's right
i didn't mean interrupt no no no uh i
thought it was necessary to demonstrate
the magnitude of this
and then and to be quite specific
in showing how much money and what is
available
and also to show
that what we don't know because i don't
know and we can't find out from the
existing public records specifically
who they talked to and what they did in
most of the cases
and equally important what struck me in
doing this is that since many of these
people are really not high visible
public known people such as a senator or
counsel to the president or a domestic
policy advisor is that what we really
have many is that many of these people
came into government stayed roughly 18
to 20 months
developed a contact list and then moved
right on out into the lobbying
arrangements but there was something
more subtle
that uh popped out
is there's a very real difference
between the executive and the
legislative branches
when you see a member of congress
in that list or other list such as
senator culver
by and large what it reflects
is a broken political career it is
someone that has lost an election and is
now going out to make a living
uh in effect using the skills and
knowledge that they've acquired here in
town paul laxalt's on the screen now yes
yes another senator uh with a
couple of uh
countries spain and barbuda and antigua
you're suggesting that there was a
broken political career it's a program
for the members of congress and in many
cases for senior staff members in
congress it's when their boss
lost the election and they're out
when one takes a look in the executive
branch however it's a very different
circumstance oh yes a deputy trade
representative for
uh some organization in bermuda almost
two and a half million dollars
uh but for the executive branch what
happens is an increasing number of
people come into office
with the idea
that they're going to make the contacts
that public service is just really a
route or a path
to public gain
and that's only possible because we have
this revolving door
we're still looking at a number on the
list that's a former senator from
georgia hermann tallmadge now this was
all these figures are during the years
1980 to 1990. only only
yes
version marsteller is a pr a press
secretary to nancy reagan and then she
was uh one of the press
spokespersons uh for george bush during
his 1988
presidential campaign
let me ask you about pat chilled for a
minute you said you were born in texas
yes
when did you leave it
uh i left texas uh i went to the
university of texas and
uh went to the university of oklahoma to
do my doctorate and economics went into
state government there
as a as a planner for the state
and
spent really until 1980 i left texas in
early 1960s
in public service i worked for the
department of commerce worked for the
state of tennessee
was involved in the appalachian program
lived and worked in west virginia in the
poverty programs for three years were
you political at all during those years
were you tied to a party no uh what
happened is
i was nonpartisan i'm still
nonpartisan
i was hired as a professional economist
development economics is my specialty
and over the years what i've done is
moved from worrying about state or
regional development to national
development
during the 1980s that's what my books
have been about
when did you move to washington uh 1975.
i came
during the ford years
as the ford administration years as
director of economic research
for an agency called the economic
development administration and there i
administered a staff of phd economist
where we studied
what kinds of federal investments could
make a difference
in the underdeveloped parts of the
country that would assist them
to do training to build hospitals roads
those things that are necessary for
basic development of local economies is
that a political appointment no no it
was a career civil servant when did you
leave that job
i left that job i went over to the white
house during the carter years and was a
senior economist on the reorganization
project of economic and community
development and then from there
i went with an organization called the
academy for contemporary problems which
was founded by the battelle memorial
institute and in fact worked out of the
same building where c-span is located
doing studies and books and
in 1981 april of 1981 i was hired as an
economic advisor policy analyst or trw
to assisted senior officers
in their external relations on broader
public policy issues not lobbying but to
talk about competitiveness and
other issues and to write and assist
them when did you leave trw uh in august
of this year august 1990. were you
surprised that trw
got irritated about this book and said
we've got several relations
uh when i began the book i had an
extended conversation with the then
chairman and in the process of
that discussion
i
thought it important that they
understand
the book and the nature of the book
and as you may remember in 1988 i did a
long piece in the washington post and
outlook which in effect is the synopsis
of the book and so i was a bit surprised
yes
what do you do now
well i'm
going to wait until this particular
book has run its life which
will be sometime i would think early
next year
and uh i've had a couple of offers from
think tanks and other organizations i'm
going to seriously consider them
and wherever i am i'll probably
pitch myself into another book
in the middle of this book are lots of
stories
it seems like there's a heavy emphasis
on u.s trade representatives i remember
the name harold
malmgren yes
the name william eberle yes
the name robert strauss yes
and the current u.s trade representative
carla hills yes correct did she ever do
any work for japanese firms before she
became current u.s trade representative
in the mid-1980s
she
registered with the justice department
as a foreign agent for daiwu which is
korean corporation and in her disclosure
files when she became ustr
she listed that she had given business
advice to matsushita which is a large
japanese electronic congarment the
firm that is bidding on mca
does that give you a problem that
somebody has had that experience before
they get to ustr
it is uh somewhat troublesome
harry mcpherson who is a
was a general counsel to lyndon johnson
very distinguished and knowledgeable
lawyer around washington made the point
that no lobbyist is born with a position
on catalytic converters that what
happens is after a lawyer takes a client
they in effect begin to develop
arguments for that client
they come to the point where they knock
down
the arguments against that client and
bit by bit
what happens is the attorney begins to
integrate the client's view and the
representation of that view into their
own worldviews
and that what happens is long after the
client is gone
the attitudes and the views are
integrated into the views of the lawyer
or the advocate themselves and it
becomes in effect their views they it is
literally an interesting
metamorphosis
i think it would be less troublesome to
me of having foreign agents or lobbyists
move into these positions if we had a
clear understanding when they moved into
these positions that when they moved out
of them
they would never again be a lobbyist for
anyone domestic or foreign i mean
i think within the context of our
political system
is that it would be very wrong to have a
discriminatory and if not
unconstitutional standard between what
we permit american companies to do and
foreign companies to do except on some
basic things such as contributing
or participating in the elections itself
so what i'm advocating is that for
positions such as the united states
trade representative or national
security advisor or secretary of state
or commerce is that a condition of
employment b is that when they leave
office they can be a lobbyist advisor
counselor on political matters
to no one domestic are foreign you have
any hope that that will ever be enacted
by this government i think uh it will
not be enacted by this government under
normal political circumstances uh quite
literally there are too many republicans
and democrats too many liberals and
conservatives
that are participating in this type of
political enrichment
watergate was only possible because the
democratic
congress was taking on a republican
administration and president
ronald reagan's success was only
possible because he was able to mobilize
a conservative constituent
against what he at least characterized
as a
liberal
uh political
establishment as i point out in this
book and as uh i illustrate in the
appendix i evenly divided between
republicans democrats liberals and
conservatives to say that this is
neither a partisan nor an ideological
issue
what that requires i think
in this town if we're going to have
changes and have the
type of integrity that we require in the
administration of our public affairs is
the american people themselves are going
to have to make special demands
upon
uh their elected officials to institute
these kinds of reforms but when you
quite literally when you break it down
almost to a trinity of reform is to say
those who represent us can never profit
from that by being a political
representative of a foreign government
or a domestic corporation that we want
full
registration of all lobbyists so that we
can know who is speaking for who and
that we will not permit through backdoor
means foreign money into our political
system this is a minimal set of
standards
and it is very difficult for the
political establishment to resist that
when the cry in demand is made and
that's one of the reasons i wrote this
book is to say to the the people is that
the corruption that now exists in our
democratic system in principles really
does threaten
much that we hold dear in this country
and that
we must do something about it that we
cannot depend on the normal political
processes to solve this wasn't that what
you were doing for trw though for the
last nine years that's correct
did you have a conscience problem doing
it
oh no doing want
lobbying the government and buying your
way into uh politics no
in the trw structure it was
split very carefully
trw maintains lobbyists that lobby
my work involved no lobbying whatsoever
it was to work on longer broad broader
issues
such as
what kinds of changes
are required in public policy to promote
better training of the workforce what
kinds of changes are required that would
permit us
to have a trade policy that could be
sensitive to the differences in cultures
between
canada europe japan
uh latin america so in a very real sense
the work that i was doing at trw was
very much akin to the work i was doing
when i was at a think tank
isn't it all the same though i mean you
were writing and appearing on television
and radio shows and representing trw and
you were the
economist with integrity and knowledge
and all that and everybody gets a good
feeling from what you say you would
testify on the hill and isn't that an
indirect way of lobbying no it is uh in
effect
arguing an issue and arguing it totally
in public and in all of my statements
that were put out in all of my books i
was always very meticulous to make sure
of two things
one is to make the point that i was an
employee of trw
so or so the listener or the viewer or
the reader could have that information
so they can make a judgment on what i'm
saying
and at the same time to also make the
point
that many of the views may or may not
necessarily reflect the corporation and
again putting that out so the viewer the
listener
could
balance off their views of what they
were saying and one of the points that i
make in the book is that very often
in the lobbying arena what happens
is those that are
advocating certain positions
never really reveal the source of the
funds behind them
and policymakers the general public the
press
at a minimum need to know that it may
well be
that
there's no relationship between
people's source of livelihood and their
views
but
the public deserves to know
the information so they can make their
own judgments back over the amount of
money that japan spends in the united
states every year lobbying how much
i would i
go on the record that they
invest 100 million per year in this
community
and then the japanese are investing
roughly 300 million a year into what we
would call grassroots politicking what
in
their publications they call long-term
lobbying
activities what can they do in this
country in this kind of activity that we
cannot do in theirs
we cannot
hire high-ranking former government
officials in japan on a mass scale to go
back and petition the japanese
government and provide
detailed information why
because in japan
it is simply against uh uh this is the
the culture of japan i
interviewed uh uh officials in uh
ministry of international trade and
industry in the foreign ministry in
japan
and one of
and one of the questions that i would
ask them is
uh what would be the reaction here if
your current vice minister were to leave
and come back in a year's period of time
and we're representing ford or general
motors trying to change the rules and
regulations here and
it was it was a shocking question to
even ask the
people and they'd say well we would be
very courteous
but we wouldn't pay attention because we
would realize this would be a bought man
and
more importantly when you would go out
late at night and have candid
conversations as tends to be the case in
the the dynamics of japanese social
relationships
the people would say not only would the
person be disgraced but his family would
be disgraced
now that is not a standard that's unique
to japan
that is found in germany it's found in
britain it's found in france it's found
in italy
what it says
is that other societies
expect those who have charge of
decisions that will affect the fate of
the nation
to comport themselves in such a manner
where there is absolute assurance that
there's full integrity in the decisions
that they make
it it is a standard
uh that i admire it is a standard that
we should adopt
there are
no more american television sets say
part of a zenith zenith television set i
think even some of that's
made in mexico it's assembled in mexico
but unfortunately the best jobs are
still here in the united states but it's
the lone remaining american television
manufacturing company
did
this system the american system of
politics have anything to do with that i
mean
were we our own worst enemy in that
yes uh it was quite what happened is
the japanese in the early
in the mid 1950s formed
a cartel inside their own country what's
a cartel a cartel is several
companies coming together
where they're going to act in restraint
of trade where they're going to in
effect join together and use
anti-competitive practices to attempt to
totally control a market to squeeze out
competitors and to squeeze from the
consumers
a profit level that would not would not
normally exist if they were full
competition
so the japanese companies came together
they farmed a cartel
uh they in effect agreed upon prices
they had agreed upon uh the levels that
they'd permit their distributors uh to
charge
they agreed that in their own
distribution networks that
other
manufacturers japan japanese are foreign
would not be given access to those
distribution networks they went to the
japanese government and they were able
to get the japanese government who
worked hand-in-glove with them to
exclude competitive foreign
sets
the japanese then manufacturers then
raised significantly the price of
television sets in japan as recently as
1975
a set a 19-inch set that would sell
for 350 in the united states would sell
for over 700 in japan
they used
that excess profit then
to come to the united states
and sell their products here
in many cases less than production cost
in an attempt to drive the american
manufacturers out of business they do
that on purpose deliberately
the japanese government how do you know
that
i know that from documents from the
japanese fair trade commission
in the postwar period
the occupation authorities set up
something called the fair trade
commission which was interested in
consumers sort of an anglo-american or a
western view to promote competition that
prohibited
anti-trust
like activities or cartels or monopolies
and soon after this cartel was formed
the japanese fair trade commission
found out about it gave them an order to
cease and desist but what also was
happening at the same time within the
japanese bureaucracy there was another
fight underway and another agency called
midi and it was interested in
strengthening producers so it was
consumers versus producers the producers
in the industries won out and so though
there were the orders there were the
findings there were the investigations
it's on the public record in japan
the policy of the japanese government
has been benign neglect as we move into
the 1960s and 70s the japanese
government has sanctioned 92
cartels former cartels and a whole host
of other areas where the industries get
the protection of a closed market for
competitive foreign goods can't come in
at least in the point where the foreign
good could make it down into the market
there's a sharing of information some
money is put up to assist the firms at
the pre-competition stage and then these
firms move abroad in a predation uh that
attempts to drive the uh foreign
manufacturer out of business with uh
activities that are illegal be quite
honest let me ask you about the all
these sets that we're used to here the
sony toshibas and mitsubishi all those
sets that we see and a lot of americans
buy
can the zenith be sold in japan
no
uh you still as recently as 1975 when
five million sets were sold in japan
only 500 foreign sets
were imported but
because they're excluded i mean quite
literally
why do we allow that to happen well we
allow it to happen because the japanese
have enough political influence to
deflect it in the story that i tell in
the book which is i think
uh
illustrative of a broader case
is what happened in this particular
circumstance
is when the american manufacturers
discovered the japanese sets were being
dumped they filed a petition the
treasury took three years to make a
ruling uh on their petition we other
words they were denied relief from this
predation that they were owed under the
law
then we moved into the nixon
years and again
economic matters
were of a low priority to richard nixon
and henry kissinger i mean quite
honestly foreign policy and defense
considerations were priority they would
trade off economic interest but this
predation continued
and as it continued we moved into the
carter years
and in that eight year period from 1968
to 1977
we went from 28 to six american-owned
manufacturers when we came into the
carter years something very interesting
happened television manufacturers
television manufacturers when we moved
into the carter years
uh it had then begun to be learned that
not only were the japanese dumping sets
but they were paying illegal rebates
kickbacks in effect to many of the
american distributors of thirty five
forty dollars a set which in addition to
the dumping price was really uh just
cutting the ground out from under uh the
american manufacturers illegally
they were filing false custom duties as
these goods were brought in
that the distributors couldn't know in
forty dollar kickbacks perfect crime i
could find out well what happened is is
one of the distributors
uh went into the customs service and
reported at the advice of their lawyer
what they were doing
and once they reported what they were
doing
the customs service took it to the
justice department and began a grand
jury investigation across the country
and then the scheme that particular
scheme uh was revealed and so but what
was also happening as this was
unraveling uh in the early 1970s the
japanese hired
a former uh deputy united states trade
representative amanda haram algorithm
five japanese companies paid him three
hundred thousand dollars to help affect
a agreement
with the carter administration
and the essence of that agreement was is
first is the japanese and public at
least
would agree to something called an
orderly marketing agreement where they
would limit their imports to a million
and a half cents a year that was
essentially a meaningless agreement
because they had roughly a million sets
in american warehouses and they had
bought many of the old american
companies for 30 cents in the dollar and
so they could produce the sets and fill
it there but what was some here in the
united states produce them here in the
united states assemble them really in
the united states but what was also not
reported at the time
is that a secret protocol
was made between the u.s and the
japanese and under the secret
protocol
the u.s agreed
that it would go against zenith in a
countervailing judy case that it had won
in a lower court and the united states
literally went against zenith as a
friend of the court brief all the way to
the supreme court where was this secret
agreement made who who made the secret
it was made by the carter administration
that was signed by robert strauss in uh
the spring of 1977 soon after they came
into power and he was in he was a u.s
trade representative he was a special
trade representative at the time he was
the person in charge of the
of the uh
america's trade relationships with the
with the japanese
let me jump before you finish that but
then if you go to your appendix you'll
find that robert strauss and aiken gump
the law firm which he is a major partner
and gets a tremendous amount of money
today from japan his law firm does
robert strauss is not registered as a
lobbyist
for any foreign interest
briefly after he left
the carter administration he registered
as a lobbyist for the people's republic
of china
but that lasted only briefly and
subsequently he has not
officially been
a foreign agent for any foreign
government or any foreign corporation
though
his law firm does represent a japanese
corporation what does that mean though
let's say that does that mean he cannot
pick up the phone and call anybody and
and talk to them about
a japanese problem
he could uh but the
registration laws are so porous
today it would not be
incumbent upon him
to register that so a lawyer in his firm
can go and say i'm with bob strauss's
law firm and i'm here to talk to you
about such and such so you get the
connection right
i guess really what i want to ask you is
whether or not if you took the bob
strausses and the harold malingams and
all these people that used to be in the
government who are now making money off
of representing foreign companies
out of this process here in washington
would it make a difference and would we
have 28 television american television
manufacturers still in this country i
think it would make a big difference
uh would it make the difference it would
make uh if you buy your way
into this town and into the politics if
the american companies are making
first-class goods and services and the
american companies were with the
televisions
uh if you close the revolving door it
would make the difference because what
would happen
is those who are in office who are
negotiating from america would know
that the person across the table with
whom they were negotiating would there
be no possibility that they would be a
client and so they could be hard-nosed
on them can you buy
american politicians
you've always been able to buy american
influence let's say
in this country
the difficulty that we have today
is that
many of the decisions are made by the
executive branch they have great
latitude and authority many of the
people who come and make the decisions
are simply passing through only going to
be there for 18 months
when they come and pass through
they're attempting to develop a client
list put yourself uh and you were down
in the carter administration you were
around the forward and the forward
administration but put yourself back in
as a civil servant okay or anybody even
even a politician
and so here you have
a scheme that the cartel in japan has
come up with to run american television
manufacturers out of business and these
people come to the door and you know
that they're going to run american
television manufacturers out of business
why would you why would you go along
with that they're only going to run them
out of business
uh if you permit them to run them out of
business uh there are american laws to
stop this but why do you permit them
that's what i'm getting at why would
somebody with a clear conscience an
american uh serving an american job in
american government say to whoever
whether it's bob strauss or or
mr eberly or any of these people say
sure we'll work out this deal why would
they want to do that there are many
justifications for it you might make it
under the argument is that we'll do it
because we want the japanese to continue
to have military bases you might do it
under the basis that we want the
japanese to stay into the gat
negotiations you might do it because
you're worried about u.s japan relations
the japanese really do understand how to
play our politicians like a stradivarius
i mean quite literally they are fully
prepared and have been fully prepared to
make a commercial issue a litmus test of
u.s japan relationships now in the past
when we had an economic easy economic
superiority
it was of less significance the point is
it's becoming much more
costly when we trade off our jobs in our
industries for foreign policy reasons
there's a million
million self-justifications for this the
other thing that though that i point out
is we have had cases of what i consider
just to be sheer irresponsible greed we
had
a senior official in the justice
department who was responsible for
extraditing
criminals back to the united states
including members of the meddling
cocaine cartel left office and goes to
work for the bosses of the middling
cartel you name that person yes i do
michael abel and moreover
this person went to spain when one of
the colombians had been captured by the
spanish government and testified against
the justice department his old
colleagues to help the guy not come back
and has worked to weaken our extradition
treaties we've had in the midst of trade
negotiations on textiles and auto parts
people change sides in the middle of
negotiations this is aberrant
behavior
it is not the norm
but what we've also had is this very
more this much more sophisticated
movement of people soon after they leave
office uh on to the foreign payrolls and
onto the payrolls of uh the foreign
corporations we're running out of time
rapidly and there's another chapter that
i want to touch on very quickly and i
want to ask you to define these
six different excuses that you say the
japanese make quickly if we could so we
can go through them and this is a whole
chapter you say that japan always has
these excuses whenever it comes to the
challenge of why this is all
whether
you know why why the differences of
opinion between our two countries excuse
number one japan creates jobs for
americans uh the fact of the matter is
is all foreign investment in the united
states in 1988 only created 32 000 new
jobs what is counted as new jobs in this
propaganda are the jobs in the companies
that are taking over and when you take a
look at many of these companies you've
actually had closeouts of part of those
facilities i think that the real uh
job situation is that there's been a
negative but remember for all foreign
investment european canadian and japan
it's only thirty two thousand it's only
five percent of the jobs that were
created so all those automobile
companies built around the united states
only amount to this many jobs yeah but
what you had is you had seven uh
japanese plants created you had seven
american plants close okay
excuse number two japan's critics are
racist this is the ad hominem attack
that we were talking about earlier if
one raises a criticism about japanese
practices one can almost assume
automatically is that you'll be attacked
as a japan basher are a racist i mean
the first line of defense is to make an
ad hominem attack against critics what's
that homonym it means personal
excuse number three it's america's fault
uh the argument here is that americans
don't build good
goods that are top quality that they're
worthy that
the americans don't try to understand
the language that we don't try hard
enough the reality is when american
goods come up against japanese goods in
europe and other countries
we win a good number of the cases the
reality is
the america's fault argument is really
saying to us try harder it's just an
excuse to keep us out of their market
when we have competitive goods excuse
number four globalization globalization
is the argument that it really doesn't
matter who owns the companies and
controls the manufacturing
in the world that we're policy
sophisticates shouldn't worry about this
the reality again is is that in europe
the europeans will permit
foreign investment on a massive scale
nine percent of the manufacturing base
in germany is far known in the united
states nine percent in japan only eight
tenths of one percent of the
manufacturing base is far known only 15
japanese companies were purchased by
foreigners last year so globalization is
for us and not for them
these are the excuses that the japanese
make when we attempt to get them to open
their market or take our competitive
excuse number five japan is unique
uh we've had a number of arguments here
that japan can't take american-made
blood analyzers because japan's blood is
different the japan can't take
foreign-made skis because japan's snow
is different the japan can't take
american timber because amer because
japanese earthquakes
are different the japanese unique
argument is used to deflect
attention except when the revisionists
have made the argument that japan is
different and should be treated
different and then the japanese reject
the argument this paragraph jumped out
at me you quote a an american an unnamed
american japan watcher
and this is what that person said it
says quite a bit about the innate race
consciousness of japan a non-western
non-christian non-arab country with no
native jewish population and no history
of conflict with israel that it is now
reaching out into other cultures to find
new categories and new outlets for its
own racist impulses
the japanese are
very insular and we have these instances
that appear over and over again
of this
rash of attention to clearly
anti-semitic literature within japan
we have
the
high-level government officials uh time
and time again making slurs against
black americans uh the japanese are
obsessed by the question of race and so
we're running out of time i gotta read
this this observer says but then the
japanese tend to think of all
non-japanese as inferior
this is uh this is a real problem
and so this is
the basis of many of these charges of
racism if in effect one makes a
criticism they say it's racism in many
cases it's just merely a projection as a
last question but you say when somebody
criticizes you that this is not a japan
bashing book this is a washington
bashing book what we're seeing is the
corruption of our democratic principles
it's our country americans are the only
ones that can stop this well agents of
influence the author is pat cho thank
you very much for joining us thank you
brian
[Music]
join us this sunday on booknotes for a
look at presidential elections with paul
taylor political writer for the
washington post
his new book see how they run electing
the president in an age of mediocrity
examines the role of both candidates and
the media in the american electoral
process
that's sunday on our companion network
c-span at 8 pm eastern time 5 pacific
[Music]